voodoo
持っています
ああああああ
止めます
あんまりインポのゼーションはうまくいき
ませんでした
鮭私履歴書を書くときに職員は欄があり
ますチョコになーんてコーポなんていつも
考えるんですけど街歩きって書くようにし
ております仕事だった
にょ実は歩いてきたんだよねポーン後田中
がこの鹿児島大学の中を歩く街歩きって
いうの企画して界のスーパースターでいき
ましたそうなんですよこの辺り面白結構
ってねえ飯面白かった池もあるし神様もい
たりして森もあったりしたよね今
ファイター馬が犬
二の中に入って開けませんて看板もあっ
たりとまあまあ消してるとこってないかな
ないよねこんな住宅チームだからねぇ
そうなんですよ街歩きをすると本当に
色んなモノ見つかりますということで私
こんなの毎日のようにしてるんですねさて
街を歩くといろんなことが3つあります
例えばこんなものの中と飲み行っちゃう
砂場
もう
本日はですね
菅原道真この腰掛石なんですよ学問の神様
ドレスわーっ
ちょっと見えてるじゃんめっちゃを知り
小さくなりそうそう
マジっていうそこ面白いんだよねー
こんなものもでやります
皆さん事務所はも叱りたい時には恋とが
いいよねぇ
でああ
エスカレーターが付いてるんだね小川
そうそう結構文明出来だしでもさー入り口
がないよね
をいろんなものがありますからね
こんなものもありますああ
ちょっ危険を予告している看板だね
でもマグしってこんな動物だったっけ
あっ明らかに来づらいよねー
大隅半島にコブラがいたっていう後初めて
知り私初めてシーンが近郊でコイン式なん
だので素晴らしい
これもありますうわああそこでだんっね
階段ハイガー
階段なんてどこでもあるけど見てください
道路拡張によって階段のこんな感じだった
んですよ
しているところがかわいいよねまるで
オブジェのような階段様坊家の支えは出れ
ない江戸大将そうで私がこれ地元の
メディアでこれをしようお返した時にこの
地域の人たちが大きな勘違いしまして実は
なんつったかというとこんな素晴らしい
ものがあるということでこれ壊す予定だっ
たらしいんですけど鉱山が決定したぞ
キャリパーも晴れてどうぞありがとう
ございます
これ所がわかる私知ってるよこーね行って
お参りをするとあのレク2をかぶっていく
と願いが叶うって言うに釜蓋神社
ああああ南九州の a で a ここでも
パワースポットだよねそうもう近年を
ぐんぐん伸びているパワースポットって
これはパワースポットなんだけど僕は好き
なものはもう一つあります
地域んおばあちゃんがいっぱい集まってる
ね居心地がそうそうだよねー
私はこれをババアスポットって a
ここもいろんなエネルギーを感じるよねー
めざて確かについてで一番居心地のいい
ところを知ってらっしゃるよく知っている
これまた北詰んじゃうからねぇ
こういうの大好きですねはい
さていよいよ私が大好きな便所のコーダー
がやってまいりました
太鼓台だけ僕待ってたけどねいつ来るか
なーと思ったんですけどこれいいですよね
これ便所なんですよ普通でしたら便器が
ありますよねあの便器っていうのは内側に
つけるべきなのでちょっと側の神社の便所
なんですけど外側に結構開放的なんですよ
だがここで男性が用を足そうと思うと
いろんなものが見えてしまうというんです
ねー
すばらしいですねー
だからオブジェかもしれないよねそうだね
is 予定っちゃっないのかもしれない
じゃんっていう人が多いこういうねー
ブービーを作ったことがあるけど
ブーバーすごいねうっでんっていうか最初
は今ちょっと珍しくなった電話ボックス今
結構なくなりましたよねはいてるなーって
いうもボックスがは結構こんなとこあるん
だと思って誰が電話をかけるんだと言って
見てぱっと開けたら便器があっなるほど
ねぇ取ったよってば僕つもこういうある
意味だ使い方をすかちょっと透けてるよね
つけてるだけじゃなくてこれね緑色塗って
やるんだよこれがかっこいいよねぇまあ
あるの保護色みたいな景観に配慮している
便利ですよながらブライヤー
これ芝居だねぇ
これもすごい大好きだねこれもねーああ
ああ室代金を置くにまた便器があるそう
そうでもこれって金谷の方なんですけど
信号待ちしててパッと予防みたらある便器
が見えたんですよねそう言って信号で偶然
赤で泊まれてタッチみたら見れるかも知れ
ということは信号待ちをしている人だして
からいろんなものが見られるといいですね
みなさんでしたこれね
はいた栗鼠もうこんなもんって寝床では
あるんですけどついついこういうものを
見つけてしまうでも見つけるだけじゃなく
てこういうものをいろんな人たちに知って
ほしいということで私は世界遺産なる世間
遺産という形でこういったものを認定させ
ていただいておりますでこれを色などが出
ますあのありがとうございます
いや08してくださいありがとうござい
ますでも遺産っていう名前を付けるだけ
あってやはりこれにはある程度の価値基準
が必要だなと思いましたということで私は
3つ価値基準を設けておりますそれが何か
というとこちらですどこか奥深いという
ただ便所があるわけじゃないただで山北数
があるわけじゃない調べてみるとそんな
ストーリーがあったんだ地域の人たちが
そういう拘りを持ってたんだっていうそう
いう奥深さがあるもの私はにし認定して
おりますそれからもう一つがどこか
懐かしい勉励してもそうですババア
スポットにしてもそうです特別なものじゃ
ないんですよどこでもあるんですよそこも
実は大事だと思うだから皆さん誰でもどこ
でも2られる急いでお渡し大事だと思うよ
ねでもだからといってみんながみんな知っ
てるよというもの例えば西郷さんの銅像と
かあれを世間遺産ですでもみんな知ってる
じゃんってことになりますよねそんなもの
はあったっけっていう密かな部分だから
どこか奥深くどつくどこか懐かしくどこか
なという声が私は大事だなぁと思っており
そうだったんだそうだどボーボーで3 d
だねって言ってくれた人がいたよかっこ
ええ
いろいろなばりに叱られ
でもですねぼくどこかっていうあいまいぬ
を残してるんですけどここ実は大事なん
です隙間て大丈夫いろんなものがそこに
入り込んでいるいろんな人たちがある意味
ではそこでか彼はてくるそういう場面を
たくさん作りたいなと思っております
で年リューターさんでもこれだけじゃなく
て龍太郎さんついてきてくれるものと思う
家大丈夫大丈夫大丈夫そういう面もあるん
じゃないかなーっていうことを今回の分析
してきましたっありがとうございますひと
つはね
yuta さんは知ってほしいっていうに
強い思いを持っていると思うがパッション
ねー
なんかも場所か
僕はやっぱり板にこんな物好きでしょ
すごいですよねこれこれは屋久島に行った
時です屋久島の国分の吉田という集落なん
ですけど周りが石に囲まれている集落など
でも地元の人たちこれが当たり前だと思っ
てたんですね最初私が入った時にこの医者
珍しいですねここだけじゃないんです集落
のいろんなところには岩の家に上に畑作っ
てたりそうそうね自分と時方に聞いたら
あれみなさんまたの地域には医師はないん
ですかっていうあるわけないよねーよこれ
もう年でもそこが素晴らしいそうだから
知ってもらってもらいたいと思ったんです
ねこれますけどさーいーねー
今日はね母の日母の日バージョンという
ことですよね
ブーバーはぁっ
懐かしい感じなのに結構で作ったって
こっちこちら感じ売ってるマグでかつ大町
のの人魚かよっていうねそのあたりがタバ
ナンですよ
あとねもう一つね方へたで特徴もあると
思う
龍太郎さんは頭にかして人神残したものを
見てやるぞ
ですねあーなるほどミッションねサーそれ
あるかもしれないねん
上場ねこれとかぁああ
これ変哲もないような給水塔なんですけど
これかなやってどこになりますかねあなた
課すという港に行きました戦前の頃にここ
に大きな紡績場があったみたいでそのもう
関工場で使われてた給水塔らしいんですよ
でも今地元の人もほとんど知らないんです
女共に紡績工場があったんでも給水塔を
唯一その紡績工場があったってと伝えて
くれるんだからこれがあることによって
そういう地域の産業史が見えてくるだから
見直したものなんだけどでも伝えることに
よってなるほどなぁってなったりするん
ですよねバーこういうストーリーとああ
ああこれ素晴らしい
これも南九州市川辺ってどこにありました
いってびっくりしましたこの集落皆さんが
他の地域にもよく天狗の伝説っていう
いろんなところにあると思うんですこの
ティングの伝説は緩いどういう幽霊かと
いうと実は政府はですねこの集落に飛んで
きたそうですでこの石の上に乗ってまあ
ここにですねくぼみができてるわけですよ
ねでまぁ左足のするとところがですねここ
に来たテグはですねその集落を見えたして
いいところで何もいることがないという
ことでそのまま跳び去ったらしっああああ
ああ
諏訪緩いですよねテープはなり顔したん
じゃなくて介在時間がた分5秒ぐらい
それなのにここの地域の人たちはこれを
どうにか地域のまちづくりに生かしたいと
いう脳がそれはいやそれでも僕は打たれた
んですこれを紹介しないとだ
赤さあこういうさあ看板の写真と言ってる
そうなんですのみある看板とまで大好きな
んですよこれは種子島で行った時に
エスパーでからおけるボロボロ洗う気に
入ってある橋行きほどメキシカンロックを
歌ったけど猫なんだねーまあそうなんだ
けどこの看板はいいんだよね確かに種子島
だらサーファーがいるということでまあ
こういうサーファーの所成果のでうしどり
いるのが理由がわからねぇこれ版権やばい
と思うじゃないどだろロックだろうか言っ
とダークならがよくわからないよくわから
ないですオリジナルかもしれねえ名前
スパーティースパーダ消したぁか出てると
思うねその文ねあとでも一番凄いのが地域
の人と一緒にこんなもんを見つけてきた
よって言って来てくれる時の話が私は
すごくさーああなるほど願えばねこういっ
た感じああそうなんでしょセッション
見つける人一緒に歩く人によって見える
ものが変わってくるこれ徳之島に行った時
です私は徳之島の方に聞きました徳之島で
車を停める時にこんなと見方をするんです
かね違いますそれじゃああて止めるって
なかなかできないよ
石上そうこれすごいなぁと思ったね暦
サティ一層だぁーこれで僕が築いたんじゃ
ないってこれたら水とこなんだけど地元の
観光ガイドの研修で行った時に韓国街道人
が僕に言いました東川さんが好きそうな
ものがある確かに大好きだったこの4着の
リズムかんっにょながらできないよねが
偶然のサーブこれはその時しか見れなかっ
たものかーされ首相殺生のダメなとこへね
ああこれも良かったねやーさっきもリズム
だったけどこれもそうだよねパッチワーク
みたいでかわいい奄美大島に行った時なん
ですよ地元の方と一緒に歩いた時に奄美の
街でも一番大事な場所のひとつである昔
教会だったその記念碑の横パッと見たら
これだったああすごいよねーハードタール
たあるタオルタオル
ゲーム the あれ
話の便座牛同士確かにコーヒーが乾いたと
思うんだねー
新しいねー
の見つけては写真を撮って責任村ですって
言って写真を撮る私はそのステティンさん
の写真を撮ってる龍太郎さんプロのが好き
だけどなそんなに毎日前に写真を撮ってる
のキョンと方向性があるんだよ世間様にも
がこれです多様な価値の共存
自分は確かに面白がっておりますでも
面白いものがどこにでも地域にある面白い
ものがたくさんあるこういう状況を作り
たいなこういうのに気づいてほしいなと
思う色んな価値があっていろんな面白さが
見方を変えるとこれも実はある意味では
地域の中では残り入らないかもしれない
ゴミかもしれないある意味では壊すれそう
なもそこも実はいろんなストーリーを見て
見てみるとじつは価値があるこんな面白さ
があるんだそういうものに気づいてほしい
というこれが僕の世間さんを通してやり
たかったことなんだよね
永久ダウンさん今日はいいこという
ありがとうございます
あの昨日までに残してたものももしかする
と明日皆さんがその価値に気付いたりとか
面白がれたりすることができるしかもしれ
ないっていうことがない俺も今日テーマの
お湯スターデートもう
チ恋ねー
あっぱねぇ
はいということで本当にですね私の話をし
てやるほどこれ誰でもできますどこでも
できますいますができます肌ですという
ことで皆さんが誰も見つけてみませんか
ありがとうございました
th